a 23 anni mi sono specializzata in
educazione degli adulti è un'amica di
mi ha chiesto
da studiarsi alla mia risposta a
sorpresa si è messo anche un po ridere
mi ha detto ma educazione degli adulti
ma gli adulti non si educano più ecco
questo luogo comune un luogo di un'idea
diffusa dalla quale mi sono liberata
circa 17 anni fa quando ho iniziato a
occuparmi appunto di infanzia e in
particolare di bambini della fascia
d'età 0 6 anni gli adulti imparano
ancora moltissimo e hanno tanto da
imparare
i bambini hanno tanto da insegnare ma
soprattutto la nostra esperienza di
quando eravamo bambini a tanto ancora da
insegnarci ci può aiutare oggi proverò
oggi a recuperare questo patrimonio che
probabilmente molti di noi hanno
dimenticato hanno disperso masi
disimparato ricordando tre modalità con
cui i bambini hanno imparato a stare al
mondo
la prima quando siamo eravamo e quando
siamo stati bambini abbiamo imparato a
conoscere il mondo a capire qualcosa di
un fenomeno facendo entrando in contatto
direttamente con l'esperienza
ricordo una esperienza di due anni fa
una scuola di infanzia dove lavoro
tuttora dovevamo affrontare il tema
dell'acqua con dei bambini di tre anni
primo a primo anno di scuola d'infanzia
avevamo due modi possibili il primo
raccontare tutto sull'acqua gli elementi
costitutivi il ciclo dell'acqua pensando
a una narrazione a una fiaba ha una
spiegazione pensando una protagonista
gocciolina che avrebbe raccontato tutto
su di sé
abbiamo scelto un altro modo in realtà
abbiamo allestito una un'aula permanente
per tutto l'anno in cui bambini potevano
entrare e trovare catini pieni d'acqua
imbuti bicchieri vasetti ciotole
cannucce potevano fare
esperienza direttamente travasare
l'acqua con tanti strumenti a loro
disposizione
potevano usare tappi di sughero sassi
foglie per fare esperienze di
galleggiamento potevano anche utilizzare
colori alimentari per colorare l'acqua o
sciogliere sale zucchero e scoprire che
l'acqua cambiava sapore potevano
prendere l'acqua per poi fare il
ghiaccio mettendo in freezer e scoprendo
che qualche ora dopo avrebbe cambiato
forma e proprio stato
ecco ai bambini non è stato spiegato
nulla ma noi abbiamo poi intervistato i
bambini per capire che cosa avevano
imparato e cosa avevano scoperto ognuno
di loro si è costruito un idea e un
sapere che è incluso a ciò che già
conosceva l'acqua in questo caso quel
determinato argomento ma in generale
sulle esperienze fatte fino a quel
momento i bambini toccano con mano si
sporcano rischiano vanno per tentativi
ed errori hanno paura a volte di toccare
di sporcarsi molti bambini sono
intimiditi e stanno a pensare prima di
procedere
entrare in azione ecco quanti di voi
hanno fatto questa esperienza da piccoli
hanno toccato con mano ve ne ricordate
avete in mente qualche episodio e quanto
da adulti ci concediamo ancora di farlo
seconda modalità da bambini più
facilmente più spontaneamente proviamo
paura e tentiamo anche di esprimere le
nostre paure le nostre incertezze le
nostre insicurezze
siamo in realtà cresciuti con uno slogan
quasi un monito che ci ha fatto
diventare grandi spesso ai bambini si
dice ma non deve aver paura ormai si è
grande questa frase ci ha accompagnato
per un intera vita
ecco i bambini si concedono proprio
perché non hanno ancora meccanismi di
difesa compiuti e solidi di esprimere
loro paure come se fossero delle
sentinelle delle spie importanti che li
aiutano poi ad attraversare quella
esperienza anche a capire come mai si
sentono minacciati in pericolo da adulti
provare paura e attraversare le proprie
paure ormai quasi non è più consentito
perché tendiamo a minimizzarle a
drammatizzare oa non affrontarle oppure
a difenderci
due anni fa abbiamo affrontato con un
educatrice nell'ultimo anno di nido la
paura di edoardo lo chiamerò così che a
tre anni appena compiuti si allenava con
un gruppo di compagnetti a togliere il
pannolino e quindi si allenava ad andare
in bagno da solo ea sedersi sul batte
rino per provare in autonomia a fare
cacca e pipì quello che si chiama in
gergo educazione al controllo sintetico
dopo qualche tempo edoardo siri si è
rifiutato di sedersi sul bate eno non
voleva più appunto avvicinarsi e
l'educatrice ha provato a capire come
mai
edoardo aveva paura di qualcosa e alla
domanda
a proprio risposto ma maestra io ho
paura del buco
ho paura di cadere lì dentro e di non
sapere dove vado ecco questa ci sembra
una paura insensata che ci fa anche
sorridere quasi davvero irrazionale
ascoltare quella paura e accompagnare
edoardo pian pianino a riavvicinarsi al
mater per poi provare in autonomia
appunto fare cache pp è stato
fondamentale attraverso anche il
passaggio dal vasino in modo che poi lui
è meno impaurito potesse fare esperienza
che non c'era un pericolo reale per lui
quante volte da adulti ci concediamo di
convivere e provare il disagio che
aderiva dalle nostre paure
quante volte abbiamo poi in realtà
dimenticato quanti paure fossero
irrazionali pensate alla paura del buio
programma andare indietro con la memoria
alla paura di una stanza inesplorata o
di una stanza che con la luce ci appare
in un modo e se spegniamo la luce ci
appare in un altro
ecco le paure e le sicurezze le
incertezze da bambini vengono
attraversate con più coraggio rispetto
alla the adulta e questo è un altro
elemento che dovrebbe molto aiutarci a
insegnarci a provare invece ad
affrontare alcune situazioni ignote ma
assolutamente sconosciute terza modalità
da bambini
cambiamo idea più spesso che da grandi
senza che questo sia un atteggiamento
ritenuto di debolezza e senza
vergognarsene ecco su questo vorrei che
oggi pensassimo anche all'esperienza di
inclusione come un'esperienza
reversibile non si è inclusi una volta
per tutte non si è escluso
definitivamente pensate
anche qui nella fascia d'età di cui mi
occupo quante volte che qui mamma papà
l'avrà lo ricorderà anche da genitori
quante volte i nostri bambini
hanno provato appunto a giocare a
conoscersi a vivere insieme e poi a
litigare e di nuova ri diventare amici
ho in mente un episodio di due bambine
di 4 anni camille lucrezia molto legate
fra loro e che di fatto dopo un momento
di gioco e di conflitto derivato dall
avere scelto un gioco che per prima
entrambe si contendevano vanno dalla
maestra dicono non sia più mi ami che
non vogliamo più giocare insieme
la maestra in vita appunto le due bimbe
a provare a ritornare a risolvere il
problema a trovare un accordo e dopo
qualche giorno camilla va dalla mese
dice maestre lunghezze ancora mia amica
adesso giochiamo ancora insieme non
litighiamo più
ecco i bambini ci mettono meno tempo
rispetto agli adulti a rientrare in
situazione ea scoprire che un conflitto
qualcosa di spiacevole può essere
superato ritornando appunto a vivere
l'esperienza disegnando era in qualche
modo insieme all'altro
pensate alla vostra infanzia vi chiedo
di tornare un po indietro con la memoria
e di pensare alla prima volta che vi
siete sentiti esclusi
pensiamo anche alla prima volta in cui
abbiamo escluso e quindi abbiamo in
qualche modo provocato un esperienza una
situazione di esclusione se penso alla
mia infanzia penso a un evento è una
situazione assolutamente che io posso
nominare come esperienza di esclusione
inclusione quando avevo 6 anni abitava
in un appartamento al di sotto del quale
vivevano 5 cuginetti il più piccolo
aveva due anni è il più grande ne aveva
11 la nostra vita viene sconvolta
drammaticamente dalla morte di mia zia
che da un giorno all'altro appunto
sparisce dalla vita di tutti noi per a
causa di un incidente stradale
da quel giorno decidiamo e di vivere
tutti insieme
mia mamma e suo fratello quindi un anno
e mia zia il mio zio vivono insieme per
crescere questi sei bambini per portarli
accompagnarli negli anni prossimi della
loro vita da bambina inclusa all'interno
del mio nucleo familiare
mi sento esclusa da un giorno all'altro
perché appunto mi trovo a dover
condividere spazi giochi tutto con i
miei 5 cuginetti al contempo io ho avuto
tanta voglia di escludere dalla mia vita
che è cambiata da un giorno all'altro i
miei 5 cugini come abbiamo fatto a
trasformare questa esperienza di
potenziale esclusione per tutti in
un'esperienza di inclusione
abbiamo deciso e negoziato su tutto
litigando piangendo facendo pace e
sostenendoci l'un l'altro abbiamo deciso
quali posti a tavola dovremmo occupare
abbiamo deciso con quali giochi giocare
con chi quali spazi occupare abbiamo
deciso i turni serali con cui la mamma
zia doveva appunto un po dedicare le
coccole prima della nanna a ciascuno di
noi
ecco questo ha richiesto un lungo tempo
di non solo appunto negoziazione
continua decisioni insieme ma di ascolto
dei bisogni di tutti questa è stata la
chiave che ci ha aiutato abbiamo fatto
così da bambini siamo diventati delle
bambine e dei bambini migliori e anche
degli adulti e delle adulte migliori
abbiamo fatto così da piccoli e in
qualche modo per perdere non perdere
questo patrimonio è stato fondamentale
cambiare idea provare paura insicurezza
e incertezza e fare per capire un
fenomeno sono tutti i comportamenti che
di solito non vengono riconosciuti
socialmente come appartenenti all'età
adulta perché gli adulti sanno già
a differenza dei bambini ecco in questo
senso
ricordo una un'immagine che parla
appunto di età delle tre età l'infanzia
all'età adulta e l'anzianità che
appartiene all'iconografia dei primi del
novecento dove queste tre età erano
rappresentate da una scala a forma di
triangolo al primo gradino si trovava
all'infanzia
l'ultimo gradino quindi l'apice il
traguardo era rappresentato da un adulto
tra l'altro maschio in giacca e cravatta
con l'idea della compiutezza dell'arrivo
del traguardo e poi discendendo fino al
gradino appunto più basso
simmetricamente corrispondente al
l'infanzia trovavamo l'anziano coi
capelli bianchi il bastone quindi
l'anzianità ecco questa immagine mi ha
sempre molto colpita e ho accettato la
sfida per anni di come dire mettere in
discussione con forza perché l'età
adulta non è l'età dalla della maturità
e della compiutezza
ma è appunto netta invece in cui c'è una
ricerca continua una ricerca continua di
equilibrio e di benessere e ho sempre
ritenuto che questi gradini hanno diviso
per troppo tempo in quel bambino è
quello adulto gli hanno più permesso di
parlare di dialogare e di essere vicini
abbiamo dimenticato per troppo tempo
come abbiamo fatto stare al mondo quando
eravamo piccoli ecco in questo caso in
questo senso vorrei davvero provare a
immaginare un'altra rappresentazione di
queste tre età e invitare tutti noi a
recuperare la bambina il bambino che
siamo stati ad accoglierlo a includerlo
e anche a custodirlo prendendo ce ne
cura perché credo davvero che sia
l'unica possibilità per non perdere la
straordinaria occasione di conoscere
sempre di più noi stessi e soprattutto
il mondo in cui viviamo
grazie
[Applauso]